what's going on guys this is rob and
word has reached my ears that the
sinister six may very well appear in
spider-man no way home so what i thought
i would do here is make you guys an
expert on the sinister six and then over
geek culture explained we'll probably
talk about how they would appear in the
movie if they were going to appear at
all having said that the sinister six is
one of the single most important teams
in the history of comic books and i
don't just mean marvel comics i mean
comic books in general and the reason
why is because at this point in time or
really up to this point in time you
didn't really see very many instances if
any of a particular superhero's villains
banding together for the purpose of
defeating that villain even in dc comics
things like the legion of doom which
appeared in the 1970s you look at things
like the rogues the villainous team that
faces off against the flash that
appeared much much later the sinister
six kind of set the groundwork for a lot
of this stuff now the sinister six of
course was created by stan lee and steve
ditko and first appeared in amazing
spider-man annual issue number one and
in reality at least as it pertains to
the spider-man mythos this was just
another instance of how stan lee and
steve ditko were just kind of the
one-two punch and in all reality at
least as it pertains to spider-man this
was just kind of another instance where
stan lee and steve ditko simply just
couldn't do anything wrong
the reason why and kind of talking about
spider-man for a second the reason why
is because as most of you guys know
spider-man is the face of marvel comics
right and i would argue he's far in a
way one of the most popular characters
to ever exist in the history of comic
books and i'm talking everybody in
general and so in the early spider-man
stories the reason he succeeded so well
was really two-fold the first was
because of the fact that peter parker
was relatable he was the kid who was
bullied at school he couldn't get the
girl he always had always struggled he
was always down on his luck and then he
got his powers and everything changed
right so it's kind of everybody's dream
scenario man i wish i was muscular
enough to get the girl or i wish i was
cool enough that nobody wanted to make
fun of me and everybody wanted to be my
friend right and while nobody was really
peter parker's friend even when he was
spider-man
he did go on to become one of the most
important superheroes in marvel the
other part of this is that because
spider-man wore a mask anybody could be
the person behind the mask so the kid
who was reading spider-man and being
bullied or made fun of or couldn't get
the girl or what have you or could in
some form or fashion relate to the
struggle of peter parker could see
themselves as the person behind the mask
and live vicariously through the comic
that they were reading and so as you
went through the early spider-man
stories the various villains that were
introduced not all of them were winners
but a lot of them were and the sinister
six was a culmination of that right the
sinister six was a coming together of
the veritable who's who of spider-man
villains all teaming up to face off
against him and what was so cool about
this when we talked about this in our
story of or at least our video
explaining dr octopus is it was one of
the rare instances that you saw with
villains at the time where one of them
was kind of elevated beyond simply just
being like blarg i'm gonna destroy
spider-man or whoever the superhero
happens to be and then i'm gonna win and
everything's gonna be okay instead dr
octopus had actually come to this
realization after having faced off
against spider-man multiple times and
lost that he wasn't the only one and
that in truth if a team was a symbol
that was composed of all of spider-man's
villains that they would be greater than
the sum of their parts the problem here
is he couldn't get everybody
only five villains were willing to help
him engage in his plan to take on
spider-man and of course those five guys
were vulcan mysterio electro sandman and
craven the hunter and so what you saw
over the course of this story at least
in the initial beginnings anyway peter
parker was was kind of losing his powers
a lot of this was predicated on the idea
of his internal guilt over the death of
uncle ben how that basically haunted him
and how it changed his life it's the one
great failing that peter parker sees
himself as consistently having in more
recent years it's also the death of gwen
stacy but nonetheless the fact that he
was struggling mentally in this way
meant the time was perfect for dr
octopus to strike and so what he did is
he basically enlisted the other members
of the six and then in turn what they
ended up doing was one kidnapping betty
brandt and on may of course betty brandt
basically being the love interest of
peter parker at the time not really his
true love you know she wasn't gonna be
the girl that he was gonna go on to
marry of course the intention was for it
to be gwen stacy jerry conway killed her
off in the 70s and it became mary jane
watson but she was his first kind of
girlfriend right the first real
girlfriend that peter parker had the
other thing is that in order to defeat
spider-man they had to break away from
the status quo the way things had always
worked previously at least for the most
part when peter parker faced off against
these different members of the sinister
six is that when a fight broke out he
would usually lure them to a location
where spider-man stood the best possible
chance of winning right very much a
playbook out of sun tzu's the art of war
doctor octopus sought to turn that on
its head and lure spider-man to a place
where the villains stood the best chance
of winning and so that's why when the
whole thing pops off and spider-man's
lured from one location to the next
after having gained his powers he fights
each member of the sinister six in a
place that's the most conducive to their
ability so for example he fights elektro
in an electrical plant the fight between
himself and craven takes place in a
nature preserve and the fight between
mysterio and spider-man actually really
results in mysterio tricking spider-man
into believing he's facing off against
the x-men and that's one of the things
that made this story so fantastic is
because it was a veritable who's who of
the marvel roster at the time while
spider-man had kind of gone missing
right basically just disappeared and
while he was truly facing off against
the sinister six nobody knew where he
was and so that's why you saw
appearances of the fantastic four you
saw captain america almost everybody
from the marvel roster at the time had a
kind of cameo in this story if for no
other reason than to solidify that
spider-man is a meaningful member of the
superhero community and that if he were
to disappear his presence would be
missed and so where peter parker is able
to gain the upper hand on each one of
these guys by basically exploiting their
powers to his own ends there were a
couple background themes that were
taking place here one of the major
themes that took place was the nature of
doctor octopus in the sense that stan
lee and steve ditko while they had done
a lot of work on auto octavius over the
time when he was being written by these
guys and drawn by these guys and the
goal was to make him a more interesting
villain this story did all kinds of
stuff in terms of elevating him into a
person who's not just kind of your
villain of the week who does bad stuff
but in the sense that like he's a
gentleman to aunt me right like there's
literally a point in the story where
he's feeding aunt may and betty brandt
like snacks
literally danish pastries to go with
their coffee
and aunt may has no real clue what's
going on now in reality they've been
kidnapped by the sinister six as a means
to basically lure spider-man in and then
try to find a way to destroy them but
the goal of otto octavius was not to
kill aunt may or betty brandt in order
to defeat peter parker the goal was to
defeat peter parker and to use them as a
means to get to him and so again while
the fight takes place between each
member of the sinister six and then
ultimately leads to a fight between
spider-man and doctor octopus which of
course spider-man's able to successfully
overcome and then saves aunt may and
betty brant and the day kind of goes on
this had a huge amount of of beefing up
for peter parker in the spider-man
mythos and the reason was this it was no
secret at the time that spider-man was
exceedingly intelligent right the peter
parker was a highly intelligent young
man the biggest problem that he had here
was differentiating between how many
instances peter parker came out on top
because of a combination of his spider
sense and his abilities in comparison to
using his brain what this story did is
it solidified this idea that with peter
parker facing off against these various
villains in landscapes and areas that
are the most suitable for them by all
standards of measurement they should win
but peter parker using a combination of
his abilities as well as his head
allowed him to gain the upper hand and
defeat these guys despite overcoming
overwhelming odds i mean quite literally
it was a gauntlet right it was one fight
after the other just one fight after
another after another after another and
so following sinister six one thing that
i do want to point out here this was
only ever designed to be a one-off
that's the reason why there's a 20-year
gap between this original sinister six
appearance in 1964 and the return of the
sinister six in 1990. now in reality if
you guys are really interested we can
talk about the different iterations of
the sinister six but truth to tell none
of them were really as interesting as
the original right as the first sinister
six and the reason isn't necessarily
because of the story the story was
fantastic it's because of the legacy
that it left behind in the aftermath of
the sinister six story and the
popularity that ensued marvel realized
quickly that there was a market for
seeing villains team up against heroes
or against some particular situation and
that's why you started seeing a lot of
stories crafted over the years in marvel
comics even decades after the original
sinister six story that built on the
premise of this as an example marvel had
a pretty obscure line of comics that
were actually called super villain team
up where you would basically have
characters that were traditionally
villains teaming up with each other to
face off against any number of things if
you look at stories like acts of
vengeance where loki had basically
brought together all the most notable
villains of the marvel landscape
switched them around and had them face
off against different heroes and then
you look at old man logan where red
skull had done the same thing but
actually succeeded all these are based
on the the framework that was
established with the sinister six even
at dc comics a lot of the stories and
the various teams that you saw coming uh
later on down the line things like the
secret six and so on and so forth a lot
of this was based on the work of the
sinister six that's why this story is so
incredibly important and that's why it's
so incredibly landmark because it
ushered in a new method of storytelling
in comics that just didn't quite exist
before but with that being said guys
this is definitely one of our shorter
videos let me know down in the comments
because i'm looking through the comments
i usually always do but i'm looking
through the comments let me know if you
guys want me to run over the different
variations of the sinister six team uh
because it wasn't always sinister six
right you had the sinister six then you
had return then you had revenge and it
was those were okay right they weren't
really that great honestly it was less
about the sinister six trying to defeat
spider-man and more about the sinister
six trying to conquer the world right so
it really kind of lost its its its
legacy its value its meaning when you
got around to those stories but let me
know if you guys are interested in
seeing those with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace